since 2009 our mission has always been  to teach and promote the value  chess brings to our community in these  times of social distancing it's more  important than ever  that we stay connected to carry on that  mission we are currently offering 24  weekly classes online through our  youtube and twitch channels  we're also holding tournaments and  private lessons online from the comfort  of their own home  students can enjoy all the benefits of  our scholastic chess initiative  digitally our scholastic outreach  continues with virtual chess classrooms  scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa  merit badge workshops  on behalf of everyone at the saint louis  chess club we hope you and your loved  ones stay  safe and continue to watch play and  enjoy the game of chess  you